you say you've seen UFOs is it ale you
believe in aliens or no they're not
aliens okay so look at it like this do
you believe in angels and demons yes
okay angels and demons are
interdimensional entities UFOs or
extraterrestrials are interdimensional
entities we are talking about entities
that exist in Dimensions that are
layered on top of our own but that we
don't perceive with our five senses this
is part of the role of the shaman so
you're saying what this is what I say I
say either people are just imagining the
alien stuff or they're demons and you're
basically saying that I'm right and Matt
Walsh is wrong no what I'm saying is
that they're Angels or demons and you
can judge a tree by its fruits now think
about it in the Bible whenever anybody
saw an angel what was one of the first
things the angel said Be not Afraid Be
not Afraid yes exactly because when you
experience these things it is so
boundary dissolving it is so
intimidating because it's so
interdimensionally incredible that the
first inclination is to be afraid an
evil interdimensional entity wants
people to be afraid because they feed on
that